[Musica]
Buonasera
all'età di 6 anni mi hanno insegnato a
leggere e scrivere come la maggior parte
di voi
in realtà Adesso si comincia un po'
prima la scuola dell'infanzia ma nella
mia epoca era la prima elementare prima
le consonanti le vocali poi le
consonanti le sillabe e alla fine le
parole quando sapevamo leggere o
scrivere una parola sapevamo leggere e
scriverle tutte e il modo che avevamo di
imparare era guidato
mi sono chiesto come avviene per la
fotografia nessuno ci ha insegnato a
leggere una fotografia a nessuno ci ha
insegnato a scattare una fotografia e
quindi è un apprendimento spontaneo come
quello della lingua
Io ho cominciato a fotografare all'età
di 15 anni
Questo sono io a 15 anni con la macchina
fotografica prestata da mio padre una
Nikon Em una macchina preferenza di
diaframma parlo ai fotografi mio padre
mi disse gira questa ghiera devi fare in
modo tale che l'asticella si ferma su
125 lui non sapeva cosa significasse gli
avevano detto di fare così lo ha detto a
me e io ho fatto così per anni ho
fotografato a un 125esimo e quello era
il dogma mi avevano spiegato che
funzionava in quella maniera In realtà
ho fotografato si può dire suonando la
macchina fotografica a orecchio e le
prime fotografie
per me erano una sperimentazione Questa
è la pescheria di Catania e
sperimentavo sulle inquadrature sulla
sensibilità della pellicola
piano piano
ho cominciato a viaggiare e a utilizzare
la macchina fotografica come quaderno
degli appunti qui sono in Albania nella
città di korce ci sono questi bambini
che giocano per strada la città di korce
gli italiani la conoscevano come coriza
ai tempi del Fascismo dell'occupazione
fascista e era in questo stato nel
1992 era caduto il dittatore enroggia e
aveva lasciato
l'Albania nelle macerie e sempre Albania
al confine tra Albania e Grecia nel
villaggio piccolo villaggio di billicht
c'era uno dei tre milioni di bunker
fatto costruire da invero oggi perché
lui cercava di proteggere l'Albania
dall'invasione degli italiani e dei
Greci Pensate un po' negli anni 90 e
accanto costruiscono le prime chiese
ortodosse Questa è una chiesa
prefabbricata e questi bunker intorno a
questi bunker giocavano i bambini a fare
la guerra
e qui sono in Thailandia c'è questa
bellissima ragazza
sorridente che intaglia fiori di papaya
da offrire in un tempio come dono votivo
nei giri continua a farvi vedere queste
esplorazioni sempre legate alla
sperimentazione della fotografia queste
Arlem Manhattan 125esima strada questo
ragazzo al centro dell'inquadratura
sembra
circondato da reti metalliche come se
fosse in carcere in realtà è un campo
sportivo e la macchina fotografica mi
permetteva di sperimentare mi permetteva
di provare a restituire la vita che
vedevo e darle una forma come dicevo
prima per me era un quaderno degli
appunti Era un modo anche per
focalizzare l'attenzione per non
distrarmi qui Sono alla fermata della
Subway Union Square e nel nell'oblò che
mi passava con sorrisi sguardi delle
persone che che viaggiavano io vedevo
mondi vite che si affollavano
Tokyo ragazze di omotesando si
travestono per farsi fotografare da
fotografie
dilettanti o anche professionisti
sono cosplayer ma non soltanto si
vestono per il piacere di essere
fotografate e la scoperta di Tokyo i
suoi quartieri shibuya shingioco che è
quello di questa foto la città elettrica
scendeco da ancita e mi permetteva
appunto
il viaggio era sempre collegato a questo
strumento della macchina fotografica e
Bahamas Nasso c'era un quartiere che si
chiama Oculus Street che era il
quartiere povero non riservate turisti
lì non era quasi possibile andare però
avevo bisogno di vedere avevo bisogno di
capire non c'erano taxi e l'albergo mi
consiglio di prenotare una limousine
quindi andare in questo quartiere
scendendo in Limousine però
cercando poi di trovare
una famigliarità per poter parlare con
le persone e fotografarle questo
quartiere è stato spazzato via cinque o
sei anni fa da un da un uragano
Il rischio è che la fotografia sia si
fermi sulla soglia della bellezza e che
non sia
legata ad un racconto sociale Allora
ho sempre pensato che invece dovesse
avere un ruolo diverso appunto sociale
appunto politico come in questo caso lei
si chiama maryen viene da Benin City una
città della Nigeria ed è stata comprata
uso questa espressione comprata da una
Maman e per liberarsi in tre anni ha
dovuto
produrre 60 mila euro per poter essere
dichiarata libera e poter andar via
dall'Italia e rimanere in Europa
lo sguardo di maryan per me è un po' il
simbolo di quello che io cercavo nella
fotografia
e attraverso questa citazione di Susan
sonta on photography è un libro
meraviglioso del 1977 lei dice far
fotografie che un modo per attestare
l'esperienza e anche un modo di
rifiutarla riducendola ad una ricerca
del fotogenico Prima parlavo di bellezza
trasformandola in un'immagine in un
souvenir la parola souvenir alla stessa
radice etimologica di sovvenire
ricordare immaginate quindi delle
fotografie che sono come le conchiglie
che raccogliamo sulla spiaggia per
ricordare una bella giornata Ecco io
vorrei che la mia fotografia non fosse
questo
al ritorno da un viaggio
Mi rubano la macchina fotografica e nel
frattempo io parallelamente vinco il
concorso a scuola
e cominciano ad arrivare i contratti
all'università e io
smetto di fotografare e comincio a
scrivere e questa è la prima mutazione
la mutazione di linguaggio dal
linguaggio sintetico della fotografia Al
linguaggio
analitico della scrittura scrivo per
circa 15 anni una sorta di
mungitura della mucca da latte nel senso
che tutti i fine settimana a scrivere
tutte le feste comandate a scrivere 12
libri 50 tra saggi articoli
è una scrittura che vivi seziona le
immagini io mi occupo di fotografia
televisione cinema non avevo più voglia
di produrre
perché ero così impegnato nella appunto
nella scrittura ma succede una cosa
all'università incontro degli amici
fotografi che fanno un progetto
bellissimo in una regione particolare
del Congo una regione di cui si è
sentito parlare in questi giorni al
telegiornale e il nord keevo
doveva andare il papa in particolar modo
a Goma ma non è potuto andare perché non
sono stati in gradi non sono stati in
grado di garantirgli la sicurezza al
Papa pensate Quanto deve essere
difficile per un
fotografo fare un reportage io ho visto
queste fotografie meravigliose dei miei
amici e loro mi invitavano e ma io
dovevo stare all'università dovevo
scrivere dovevo scrivere e produrre a un
certo punto ho detto basta seconda
mutazione decido che quella scrittura
Doveva
incontrare nuovamente il mio linguaggio
naturale che era quello della fotografia
Allora decido di partire il 16 dicembre
del 2018
loro mi dicono ci sono le elezioni
presidenziali pensate in Congo non
c'erano elezioni presidenziali da 17
anni c'era cabina figlio che aveva
imposto una sorta di regime aveva
ottenuto il potere con un colpo di stato
facendo ammazzare cabina padre e prima
di lui cambi la patria aveva preso il
potere con un colpo di stato cacciato
mobutu ssko non c'era una tradizione
Democratica di un certo tipo nonostante
si chiami Repubblica Democratica del
Congo
Andai lì e
venne ospitato da
la missione Wild ibrahimo che si trova
in un villaggio muanga 43 chilometri
dentro la foresta congolese lì c'è un
missionario c'era un missionario perché
purtroppo è dovuto tornare in Italia che
si chiama Giovanni piumatti
di Pinerolo un uomo che per 50 anni ha
lavorato e realizzato progetti lì e il
mio compito era quello di coprire si usa
questo termine tecnico coprire in foto e
video le elezioni proprio nella regione
del nord IV e così
e così
vado a bugnatelli dove Assisto alle
prime elezioni democratiche dopo 17 anni
e pensate che a curare la sicurezza era
un ribelle del gruppo degli Indù
un ribelle con il suo ak-47 il
kalashnikov fuori dal seggio elettorale
Come noi abbiamo i Carabinieri o la
polizia fuori dal seggio loro avevano il
ribelli il North kivu ci sono
122 gruppi armati di ribelli gli uni
contro gli altri Questa è la situazione
attuale e il luogo dove è stato ucciso
il nostro Ambasciatore Luca Attanasio
per intenderci
ma muanga non è solo muanga e il
norchivu non è soltanto la tragedia che
vivono che vivono i cittadini e anche
una incredibile bellezza questa domenica
pomeriggio Io ho avuto la fortuna di
poter fotografare questi bambini che
giocavano
in questo campo e c'è una bambina con
delle Margherite tra i capelli si chiama
Adele
Fare foto ai bambini per me era un gioco
Io
li facevo partecipare a questo gioco
loro stavano davanti a me poi guardavano
la fotografia che io avevo loro fatto e
sorridevano era è sempre stato per me un
modo anche per stabilire un contatto io
non parlo chi swahili capisco il
francese ma non lo parlo e qui ci sono
dei bambini che con un una macchinina
costruita con il legno intagliato e le
ruote sono tappi di bottiglia ancora un
altro bimbo che mi aspetta per andare a
passeggiare nonostante ci fosse una
pioggia ogni giorno e sulla linea
dell'equatore ogni giorno piove Ma quei
secchi d'acqua andiamo avanti e qui è il
campo di muanga a me piaceva questa foto
anche se è un po' squilibrata
apparentemente Io sono disteso sull'erba
perché c'è questo bambino che sembra
staccare dal cielo il pallone mentre
corre e ovviamente loro giocavano Scalzi
per pomeriggi interi Questa è la strada
per la scuola per muanga
e la scuola di muanga qui ci sono i
bambini che oltre ad utilizzare i
quaderni utilizzano delle lavagnette e
sono i bambini che hanno maggiori
difficoltà economiche perché le
lavagnette non hanno
vengono cancellate All'infinito E quindi
sono più economiche e anche questi
piccoli elementi entrare in classe
capire come funziona la didattica era
era era importante al mio punto di vista
andiamo avanti
e
questa lastra di
che funge da lavagna vedete in alto ma
forse non li vedete perché sono
veramente piccoli Ci sono gli insiemi
quindi era l'ala è un'aula Dove Dove
appunto
i bambini hanno la possibilità di
studiare la lingua chi swahili francese
ma anche ma anche le altre materie
e di ritorno dalla scuola
hanno
aiutato in campagna i genitori e poi
portano queste verdure
a casa Appunto
questa è una delle scene del ritorno a
casa
e questo è uno dei giochi alcuni mi
dicono sono i giochi che facevano i
nostri nonni e Un cerchione di una
bicicletta che viene spinto con un
bastone e chiudo questa questa
passerella di fotografia adesso poi vi
farò vedere un breve video e con questa
immagine perché in questo momento a
chimbulu sempre in archivio c'è un
laboratorio di sartoria che è finanziato
da una associazione italiana che si
chiama simama e
questa è una delle mamme
che stanno imparando a diventare sarte
alla fine del corso ognuna di loro avrà
una macchina da cucire e continuerà a
fare questo lavoro
chiudo con una citazione Lotta nella
cosa e scissura nella parola nell'arte
Vi si poteva sottrarre il linguaggio è
ottocentesco e Francesco De Santis il
saggio su Manzoni del 73
1873 Lotta nella Cosa significa che
nella realtà nella cosa ci sono le
contraddizioni c'è la lotta
E noi che facciamo rappresentazioni cioè
la parola dobbiamo dare forma a questa
lotta Allora esci Sura nella parola e
questo è un compito che deve avere chi
fa comunicazione
nell'arte Vi si poteva sottrarre Questa
è la mia idea di fotografia e di video
quello che vedrete adesso è un breve
filmato girato durante le lezioni quindi
vedrete manifestazioni vedrete candidati
danze rituali di benvenuto per i
candidati vedete quello che è successo
realmente
Quell'esercizio di democrazia pieno però
delle sue contraddizioni perché il
lavoro che facciamo deve rendere le
contraddizioni dallatenti a patenti
Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]